Eine große aktuelle studie zeigt die
fleischproduktion ist ein riesen klimakiller demnach sind die fünf weltweit größten fleisch und molkerei konzerne für mehr treibhausgas emissionen verantwortlich
als der ölkonzern exxonmobil ein unfassbares ergebnis was genau dahinter steckt und was sie selbst tun könnte um den globalen temperaturanstieg
zu begrenzen erfahrt ihr jetzt mal klicks von science fiction herzlich willkommen
Dass kühe beim verdauen
klimaschädliches methangas ausstoßen ist nichts neues auch nicht dass bei der weiterverarbeitung und dem transport von milch und fleisch
co2 emissionen entstehen doch dass diese branche so extrem zur erderwärmung beiträgt
dann hätte hätte wohl kaum jemand gerechnet doch genau so lautet das fazit der aktuellen studie vom institut für ex-coach and trade policy
mpp
in diesem bericht heißt das konkret
gemeinsam sind die fünf größten fleischer molkerei konzerne bereits heute für mehr treibhausgas emissionen pro jahr verantwortlich
als die ölkonzerne exxonmobil shell oder bp
wer hätte gedacht dass die ja eigentlich
natürliche produktion von lebensmitteln mit den großen ölkonzernen
konkurrieren kann dabei geht es hier um alle emissionen der fleischproduktion zusammengenommen also das ausgeschiedene methan aber auch dass beim transport
produzierte co2 und für die zukunft ist keine besserung in sicht im gegenteil
wenn man davon ausgeht dass die fleisch und
molkereibranche in den kommenden jahren weiter wächst steht uns ein kollaps bevor die macher der studie
die kritisieren die verantwortlichen unternehmen hart da der großteil viel zu niedrige werte in seinem co2 bilanz angebe auf würden die emissionen
komplett in der lieferkette
ausgeklammert oder gar nicht darüber informiert
dabei handelt es sich dabei um bis zu 90 prozent der gesamtemissionen
Nachvollziehbare und vollständige missions- berichte gab es nur von vier konzernen die studie nennt in einer liste die co2
verursache auch beim namen der deutsche molkereikonzern dmk
befindet sich auf platz 21 auf platz 24 folgt der fleischkonzern tönnies
den zweifelhaften ersten platz belegt ein konzern aus brasilien
gbs dahinter folgen drei us unternehmen mehr als unverständlich also dass die politik bis heute keine genauen
klimaschutzziele für die landwirtschaft vorgibt dabei hatte die ernährungs und landwirtschaftsorganisation
der vereinten nationen fao schon 2006 verdeutlicht welch große rolle die fleisch- und milchproduktion bei der globalen erderwärmung
spielt zwar hatte man dann beim klimagipfel in paris vor drei jahren angemerkt dass auch der nahrung sektor emissionen reduzieren muss aber
dabei ist es gefühlt auch geblieben im krassen widerspruch
dazu stehen die ziele der entsprechenden konzerne in den kommenden jahren ihr geschäft
auszubauen und zu wachsen so beispielsweise die brasilianische firma gs die davon ausgeht dass der fleischkonsum
pro kopf in den kommenden zwölf jahren um 30 prozent steigen wird das sagen die nämlich ihren investoren
dabei wäre genau der
entgegengesetzten trend wünschenswert und vor allem auch notwendig um die globale erderwärmung auf zwei oder sogar 1,5 grad celsius zu begrenzen lavigne bis
müssten die deutschen dazu ihren fleischkonsum
halbieren in den kommenden zwölf jahren auf 22 kilo singen pro kopf und jahr bis
2050 sogar auf 16 kilogramm pro person und jahr
dazu heißt es in dem greenpeace bericht damit auch die landwirtschaft einen beitrag zum erreichen der pariser klimaziele leistet und das artensterben
gestoppt wird müssen die deutschen bis zum jahr 2050 ihren fleischkonsum und 50 prozent senken
pestizide müssen von den äckern verband und die mineraldünger deutlich reduziert werden in die pflicht genommen werden müssen vor allem die
hauptverantwortlichen exportregion von fleisch und milchprodukten
dazu zählen die usa kanada die eu brasilien argentinien
australien und neuseeland denn hier herrscht eine überproduktion vor und ein
extrem hohe pro kopf verbrauch obwohl hier nur 15 prozent der weltbevölkerung leben machen diese region
43 prozent der weltweiten emissionen der fleisch- und milchproduktion aus die aktuelle studie zeigt jedenfalls noch einmal die dringlichkeit
dass nicht nur der energiesektor hinsichtlich der klimabilanz überprüft werden muss sondern auch die großen fleisch und molkerei
unternimmt die bisher bestehenden regelungen sind freiwillig und werden weder durch unabhängige
überwachungssysteme noch durch sanktionen und stützt und durchgesetzt ein
eklatantes problem für die zukunft von uns allen
schande genug dass die politik das bislang verpasst hat aber ihr könnt etwas tun und es ist ganz simpel
es einfach weniger
fleisch wenn er kein video dazu zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp dann um geht dir die etwas
unzuverlässiger aber boxer auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich von jedem upload und zwar noch vor allen anderen
täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür
hier klicken aber nicht die
glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken ja klimawandel
bestätigt skeptiker endgültig widerlegt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran